let's talk a little bit about purpose
one of the things the Masai think one of
the mistakes that people make is they
think purpose comes from their job right
and we see this in military and
non-military which is I've been a
whatever for so many years and when then
I lose my job or I retire I now don't
have a sense of purpose because I've so
closely associated my self-worth with
the job that I did and you said that
happened even in the military where I
knew what my job was I had a sense of
purpose and one wonders if those things
are conflated right which is I had a
sense of purpose for my job and then
when I didn't have the job when I left
the military Alif all of a sudden I
sense I didn't know what I woke up in
the morning didn't know what to do you
had a sense of service because of the
community and now you've found a sense
of service because you're in literally
in service to you to that community
again but it's not the job it's the
sense of service I don't even consider
it's a job or career you know I consider
my passion I'm like I will keep on doing
this you don't give your money I love
doing this and it's funny on my previous
jobs I'll get in trouble
hey you're taking too much time off like
I don't care I need to do these I need
hang out these guys I need to take care
of them I need to do I need to do and I
love it and I this this is it for me
that I've unfortunate and lucky enough
to find my purpose and yet and this is
what I want to stress to any vet who's
listening to those are watching this
which is the purpose is not your mos or
your purpose is not your assal gunner
your purpose is not the job that you
wake up to do every day your purpose is
something bigger
you